Law and Diplomacy at Tufts University he
has served on the Secretary of the
Navy's Advisory Committee on naval
history and has received the US Navy's
meritorious civilian service award and
superior so civilian service award a
senior research fellow at the Foreign
Policy Research Institute he is a member
of the Editorial Board of orbits a
journal of world affairs and the
academic board of advisors of the
Churchill Center he is associate editor
of diplomacy and statecraft dr. Maurer
is the author or editor of numerous
books including the outbreak of the
first world war military intervention in
the third world in Churchill and the
strategic dilemmas before the world wars
please join me in welcoming dr. John
Mauer
thank you so much for that introduction
I want to begin by offering my added
voice to the chorus of thanking
Hillsdale for inviting me to be here
today as a speaker
- Larry Arne for inviting me and also to
all of the Hillsdale family community
for being so hospitable and making me
feel have such a warm welcome here my
first time at Hillsdale I was asked to
talk about Churchill as a war leader and
what I want to do is take us back 75
years in time to 1940 1940 as you know
was one of the great turning points in
world history
what a dramatic year that was history if
it had gone another way as it could have
history could have gone terribly awry in
a hideous way as it was World War two
was hideous enough but it could have
been worse we can imagine how much worse
it could have been and so what I want to
do today is talk about Churchill at a
critical moment in world history the
period for which he is most celebrated
deservedly so so I want to take us back
to 1940 and those events now you heard
already about Churchill's early life and
in my early life he wrote and said well
adults called me a troublesome boy here
he is as a teenager does he look like a
troublesome boy to you well fast forward
50 years
you can see there that that troublesome
teenage boy was also going to be a
troublesome 60-something to Adolf Hitler
again what makes great leaders how far
does it go back to what are those
formative experiences that you heard
about as a young man that led him to be
a great great leader well I didn't mean
to do that question here's a question
for you
what if Churchill had not been there
this is what historians and political
scientists call counterfactual analysis
we know the history but let's imagine
alternative histories what if he had not
been there this is what I like to call
the George Bailey effect we all remember
that famous movie by Frank Capra with
Jimmy Stewart where a George Bailey has
to see a life of his town his small town
if he didn't live that alternative
future and what could have happened it
would have been pyrovile a horrible
place to live not the Kuip of community
you want your family to grow up in and
so what we want to do is think about the
alternatives of what if Churchill had
not been there that's one of the great
measures of a leader imagine if that
leader had not been there to make some
critical decision well Churchill might
not have been there because in 1931 in
New York City he was hit by a car on
Fifth Avenue he was almost killed in
fact someone of a weaker Constitution
could well have died from that auto
accident fortunately for him he had very
good medical care dr. otto pickhardt who
wrote out this prescription for him let
me read it for you remember this is this
is the United States during Prohibition
so dr. otto pickhardt wrote out this is
to certify that the
post-accident convalescence of the
Honorable Winston s Churchill
necessitates the use of alcoholic
spirits especially at meal times the
quantity is naturally indefinite but the
minimum requirements would be 250 cubic
centimeters
we all wish we had doctors like this and
we wish that our health insurance would
cover these prescriptions
oh well again imagine if he had died in
1931 in New York now typical of
Churchill here's something great
adversity he's been punished by the gods
he's been hit by a car he almost dies
many people hit by such adversity would
be down and out but instead what did
Churchill do he wrote about his
experience about being hit by a car my
New York misadventure for which he was
paid a great deal of money here he took
adversity and turned it around to good
fortune indeed that's a hallmark of
Churchill in 1940 that despite the great
catastrophe of the defeats in France in
1940 he took those defeats in that
adversity and turned it around
dramatically and laid the foundation for
the grand alliance that would go on to
defeat Hitler's tyranny well what caused
the great second world war well there's
the Great War it's the aftermath of the
Great War the First World War but also
the Great Depression the Great
Depression becomes one of the major
undercurrents that leads to the
radicalization of politics around the
world that leads to the second Great
Armageddon as Churchill called it the
New York that Winston Churchill saw 1931
this is what you would see if you go to
YouTube you can see the film footage of
this look at these men looking for a
handout beaten down they're not looking
at the camera they're looking at their
feet and when
you see the film footage you see they're
shuffling along like this these are
hungry men who have been broken their
respect has been taken away as well as
being hungry
this is what the great man-made
catastrophe called the Great Depression
that the world dealt with now countries
dealt with it in different ways what you
see here is a transmission belt toward
war the economic downturn led to the
radicalization of politics failed
Democratic States principally injurer
the economic downturn led to the
radicalization of politics failed
democratic states principally in germany
and in japan the 1920s had seen
democracy more open forms of government
in both countries the Great Depression
though radicalized nationalist movements
in both countries that then in turn that
seized power that then in turn led to a
more aggressive foreign policy on the
part of both Nazi Germany and Imperial
Japan so the economic downturn leads in
time to another Great War well who is
one of the beneficiaries of this
downturn Adolf Hitler his extremist
nationalist movement within Germany came
to power on January 30th 1933 look at
this creepy photograph what do you see
here you see their Fuhrer you see Hitler
he has his hands on that young man that
boy that 12 year old what do you think
he's about 12 yes look at that we know
the future of this young boy don't we
he's probably going to be killed over
Britain or die on the Russian front
because they're following their Feuer
their leader who's leading them to
catastrophe one of the hallmarks of the
Nazi movement was that it was a youth
movement it attracted the youth of
Germany that came across in the film
clip that
Richard langworth did of Sir Robert
Hardy's film on the wilderness years the
Nazi movement was appealing to young
people who felt disenfranchised who
didn't think they had a place think
about this this generation is blighted
in so many ways they grow up in the
shadow of the great war when they come
of age no jobs because of the Great
Depression meanwhile who have they lost
their father older brother uncles male
figures that could give stability to
their life have been taken away on the
trenches of the Western Front this young
generation is looking for someone to
lead them and this is who they found
this Pied Piper it's like a grim fairy
tale here
hijacking taking away the youth of
Germany leading them to the battlefields
of the Second World War
well in Hamlet as you've heard
Shakespeare formed an important part of
Churchill's upbringing background
understanding of life well King Claudius
says hey madness and great ones must not
unwatched and go did I do that well Sir
Robert my delivery
thank you thank you thank you you have
to watch we might find Hitler's views so
extreme to be mad but that madness is a
reality that you have to deal with
unfortunately in the world we live in
today we look at enemies that extremists
and we say we can't believe that they
believe the things they do but they do
and we have to live with them we have to
understand them we have to think that we
might not be able to change them you're
not going to change an adolf hitler
you're going to have to live with those
views though or destroy those views well
in germany churchill saw what was
happening
mass movements again look at the young
people here mobilized at all these
various German rallies the book burger
at Nuremberg and Churchill early on
highlighted what do you see here in
Germany parliamentary democracy the
rhyme our Republic that's gone it's been
swept away and look at this wonderful
language what's in its place you have a
dictatorship but not just anything you
have a most grim dictatorship boy that's
right out of Hamlet ooh it's not just
murder most murder its murder most foul
right well here you have a dictatorship
at a most grim dictatorship you can see
Shakespeare influencing Churchill's
rhetoric here well what is at stake
Churchill lays this out in the great
speeches of the 1930s and here's his
famous Munich oration condemning the
Munich pact he's laying out that this is
an ideological struggle as he says a
conflict of spiritual and moral ideals
he highlights you have to consider what
the Nazi movement stands for you have to
consider that you have to understand
them and what does Nazi power stand for
spurns Christian ethics cheers barbarous
paganism wants the spirit of aggression
derives strength and pleasure from
persecution Nazi power uses pitiless
brutality and the threat of murderous
force the bottom line the thesis is Nazi
Germany and British democracy they can't
ever be friends this is an existential
struggle right at the heart of Europe
one of the other is going to have to go
Churchill understands the danger that
Britain and indeed all of Western
civilization faces from the Nazi
challenge well how do you respond to it
Churchill says we have to have weapons
armaments and so early on early on he
called for a buildup of British airpower
so in 1934 you have him saying we ought
to double the Royal Air Force as fast as
we can
and want to have it now and then double
it again
now his critics said this is extreme
this is gonna bust the budget we don't
want to do that
this is alarmist panic mongering don't
want to do that but Churchill calls for
rearmament to become stronger to be able
to face the coming storm posed by the
Nazi threat but in addition Churchill
wants to reach out and find allies not
only armaments but find allies and one
of the great allies that he wants to
reach out to is the United States here's
a speech in the aftermath of Munich in
the fall of 1938 that he gave over the
NBC radio network to the United States
and as you can see here what Richard
talked about the way he in which his
speeches were laid out that he would
memorize them but would read from them
and also make editorial changes in them
too down to the last minute now what
does it say well we must arm Britain in
America must arm but arms aren't enough
weapons aren't enough instead Britain in
the United States have to add the power
of ideas a conflict is not just about
weapons it's about people and what
motivates people do they have the will
to fight not just the means to fight but
the will to fight and so Churchill is
trying to highlight what is at stake not
just to the British public but also in
the United States reaching out to the
United States to highlight that the
fight against Nazi Germany is not just
one between Britain and Germany but the
US will be involved in this fight as
well now of course you live in a
democracy if I put forward a proposition
there's going to be someone who
disagrees with me and in the United
States one of the most powerful figures
the great press magnate William Randolph
Hearst didn't like Churchill's message
so this is his response in an editorial
that this is propaganda it's flooding
the United States the propaganda
shrewdest a 'bless statesman meaning
Churchill and Churchill
is wrong wrong about what is at stake
for America in this coming fight by the
way a measure of a leader is not only
you know what we are what you do you
know how what if you're not there but
also another measure of a leader is how
much respect of your enemies have for
you
what are your enemies think of you are
they afraid of you or not well early on
Hitler understood the Churchill was a
danger that a Britain under Churchill is
a more dangerous Britain than a Britain
under Stanley Baldwin and indeed that
very same speech to America broadcast to
America Hitler went out of his way in
November of 1938 to offer a response to
Churchill now notice what he says here
Churchill has said that it's a spiritual
moral conflict between democracy and
Nazi tyranny
Hitler's response is to say there's been
form this custom it's calls it a curious
custom of dividing people into
authoritarianism that is discipline
States and democratic states the
implication being that democracies
aren't disciplined indeed many of us at
times think I wish we could all get on
the same page and agree well Hitler's
highlighting here this is a weakness of
democracy that authoritarian States by
being more rigid and disciplined
everyone can get into line not
understanding the strength of
democracies that very openness also
brings in participation but again notice
he sees a struggle here - between
democracy and the Nazi regime now in his
speeches Churchill hoped that within
Germany there would be a movement to
overthrow the Nazi regime
well Hitler takes this head-on and you
can YouTube this as well and listen to
this speech and when he says mr.
Churchill in German it's at Churchill I
mean you can hear it that anger in his
voice just what he mentions Churchill's
name
he says the present regime should be
overthrown in Germany well Churchill's
spending too much of his time with
traitors Hitler says that are living
abroad and England and the rest and he
should realize that that's well madness
stupidity again to Churchill who would
appear to be living on the moon there's
no force in Germany that will turn
against the present regime alas
Hitler is probably right here at this
time the opposition is broken by the
fall of 1938 Hitler's successes in
rearmament and bringing about full
employment his foreign policy successes
has broken down and beaten down whatever
opposition does exist in Germany to the
regime the regime is popular well is
there a better way than Churchill's way
and of course we associate this with
Neville Chamberlain a man devoted to
peace striving his best to preserve the
peace understanding that another great
war between the great powers would be
like the first war it would produce
massive casualties and social upheaval
it should be avoided at all costs war
should be a last resort should find some
way out of that there has to be a better
way well he was trying to find a
moderate Nazi and he thought he found
that moderate Nazi and Hitler at Munich
again writing to his sister one of his
sisters Ida they said hey I have
established a confidence with Hitler and
in spite of that hardness ruthlessness
again before his eyes he can see that
Hitler is a ruthless man but he's
somebody
well once he's given his word he'll
stick with it well we know fat chance
about that but come home this is what
you're greeted by peace this is popular
at the time when he comes back indeed
Neville Chamberlain thought about
holding a snap election because he
thought his own personal popularity and
the Tories would be so great that they
would be able to win a big election he
was talked out of it though but
nonetheless sure Chamberlain is seen as
the man who
preserved the piece and we've seen these
photographs before of him returning back
to England holding in his hand a piece
of paper signed by him and by Adolf
Hitler you can see Hitler's scroll there
above Neville Chamberlain's name as
Chamberlain was leaving Germany he put
this document in front of Hitler and
said please sign this and Hitler didn't
want to sign it as soon as it was
translated for him and he could see it
but he felt he couldn't at that point
that it would ruin what had happened at
the Munich Agreement so he signed it but
afterwards he complained bitterly about
having to sign this old man forcing him
to sign this document but again the key
is right there in the center of it the
desire of our two peoples never to go to
war with one another again again who can
be against peace well of course it's
Adolf Hitler he's against peace he wants
a war he felt very frustrated by Munich
he wanted it to go to war in 1938 well a
year later he's gonna get his war
because as he said to his intimates
those in his entourage like Joseph
Goebbels he said if that old man comes
interfering again meaning Neville
Chamberlain with his umbrella what am I
gonna do I'm just gonna kick him
downstairs and jump on his tummy in
front of the photographers look at the
contempt that Hitler has for Neville
Chamberlain
unlike the fear he has for Churchill
well a year later in August of 1939
Hitler gets his way by joining up with
Stalin Soviet Russia and Nazi Germany
Hitler and Stalin are able to get
together to trigger the next great
Armageddon World War again what do they
have in common they want to tie out to
tear up the Versailles settlement they
want a partition Eastern Europe between
them and so in 1939 September German
invasion of Poland from the West
meanwhile from the East the Red Army
goes into Poland and seizes polish
territory as well
is the trigger for the war Britain goes
to war and of course Winston is back
Neville Chamberlain brings him back into
his government his First Lord of the
Admiralty with a seat in the War Cabinet
again picture post him going to the
Admiralty building being in charge of
the Navy again a poster from the time
that the Navy guards the freedom of us
all well what was the response in
Germany to the news that Churchill is
back in the government after being out
of government for ten years well Albert
Speer who later became Hitler's
armaments minister kept the diary and he
was there when the news broke in Germany
of what happened he was outside Hitler
salon Hitler's rooms when out came
Hermann Goering Goering steps out sits
down frustrated he drops down wearily
and says Churchill in the cabinet that
means the war is really on now we shall
have war with England it was hoped by
Hitler that even if Britain declared war
on Germany they wouldn't do very much
and soon there would be a negotiation to
bring an end in a fighting but the news
of Churchill in the government dashed
all those hopes Hitler and the top
leadership understood that Churchill and
the government meant there was a fight
to the finish again the measure of a
leader is how did your enemies assess
you well Poland taken out what's
Germany's next move well in the spring
of 1940 it's to go conquer Denmark
Norway to protect German iron ore
supplies from Sweden well the campaign
of Britain and France in Norway did not
go well there were military setbacks the
Germans gained the upper hand
this triggered a debate in the spring of
1940 that would lead to Churchill coming
to power now there were no photographs
that were supposed to be taken in the
House of Commons no recordings of the
speeches of the House of Commons but
nonetheless someone was able to sneak a
camera in to take a picture of the
debate and there you see Churchill and
Neville Chamberlain sitting on the front
bench together in the government
listening to the debate as it goes on in
the House of Commons well as a result of
this debate Chamberlain holds on wins
but he realizes that he can't go on as
Prime Minister that a coalition
government has to be formed of all
parties in this national emergency
triggered by these military defeats up
in Norway Neville Chamberlain leaving
his prime minister now our ambassador to
the court of st. James was Joseph
Kennedy the father of President John F
Kennedy and Kennedy was very close to
Neville Chamberlain and in fact in their
views very similar they were both wanted
to appease Germany to avoid war at all
costs and this is what Kennedy who kept
a diary of his time recorded about
Chamberlain how broken he was well who's
going to become Prime Minister if
Chamberlain sets down and it becomes
Churchill or Lord Halifax Britain's
foreign secretary that's what the choice
is well between the two of them
Halifax had the inside track
Conservative Party wanted him Neville
Chamberlain one of them the royal family
would have been content with him to be
Prime Minister the Labour Party was
willing to serve under him there was one
problem though Lord Halifax didn't want
to be Prime Minister he confided to his
diary that the whole thought of being
Prime Minister at this crisis time made
his stomach upset well a weak tummy
means that he's not going to be Prime
Minister he could have been Prime
Minister if he wanted to be but he
turned it down and as a consequence we
got Winston Churchill don't you love
this photograph the Pinstripe soup the
cigar the tommy gun
wow this is great this is pugneeshia s--
of course Joseph Goebbels dr. Goebbels
he used this for his propaganda to
highlight because one of the German
propaganda lines is that Winston
Churchill is a gangster some Chicago
gangster like Al Capone you know there
he is well he looks like a gangster but
again I love that pugnacious Churchill
there with the tommy gun
well what's Germany's next move it's an
offensive to the west the Western Front
had been quiet all quiet on that Western
Front from September 1939 to May 1940
but in a 1940 just as Churchill was
becoming Prime Minister the big German
offensive begins on the Western Front
spearheaded by airpower German airpower
the Churchill had warned against Germany
gets air superiority over the
battlefield which enables its armored
forces infantry forces artillery what we
call combined arms forces be able to
launch breakthroughs indeed the major
breakthrough occurs along the Meuse
river it cuts off the British French and
Belgian forces in the north in Belgium
and it becomes a real horse race to see
whether the British and French forces
can escape out through the Channel ports
before that German what they called
sickle cut that German sickle cut comes
through and envelops and destroys the
British and French forces well this is a
desperate situation to be in Dunkirk
becomes the port we've seen these
photographs and newsreels of the
evacuation at Dunkirk it was thought at
the time the British chief said we'll be
fortunate to get 30,000 soldiers out in
other words the whole British
Expeditionary Force and the French
armies in Belgium are going to be wiped
out they're going to be destroyed but as
Churchill said through a miracle of
deliverance and a great deal of hard
fighting instead of 30 thousand more
than three hundred thousand ten times
the number were able to escape again it
might have been a miracle of deliverance
but as Churchill warned wars are not won
by evacuation well after Dunkirk the
Germans turned south to occupy and
defeat the rest of the French army and
overrun France German forces going into
Paris
Hitler visiting Paris
well in this situation of these defeats
on the battlefield
Lord Halifax who still remained as
foreign secretary in the coalition
government he was known as the English
parson he was a very religious very
devout man he starts to argue that this
catastrophic defeat that is occurring to
the British and French forces means that
the chances of defeating Nazi Germany
have sunk dramatically and the result is
that Britain and France ought to be
trying to find the deal to cut a deal to
cut their losses before they become
suffer even a worse defeat at the hands
of the Nazis he argued in the cabinet
for what was called realism that the
British government should be realistic
in assessing their chances of victory
that the probability of success was low
he argued in this that they had to face
the fact that trying to bring about the
complete defeat of Germany regime change
the overthrow the Nazi regime
well that wasn't going to happen and
indeed Britain should be looking to
safeguard its Empire and that Britain
should be open to any negotiation that
would lead to as he said the liberty and
independence of the British Empire now
Lord Halifax is not calling for
surrender what he's arguing for is
Germany the reality is they've won in
Europe let them have their hegemony in
Europe in return for safeguarding the
British Empire maybe Malta has to be
given off to Mussolini in the Italians
or but cut some sort of deal to preserve
the British Empire otherwise if the war
continues the British Empire will be
destroyed that's what Halifax is arguing
at the time
well Churchill would have none of it and
he argued against Halifax and closed
meetings of the British government
indeed after one of the meetings he went
in and talked to the cabinet and gave an
oration to the cabinet this is what he
said to them that you know hey I'd be
convinced that you would tear me down
I've just become Prime Minister but if I
were to contemplate parley with the jury
and then look at this in this long
island story of ours is to end at last
let it end only when each one of us lies
choking in his own blood upon the ground
Wow Wow powerful you know what the
cabinet's response was hurray that's
what we want to hear they backed up
Churchill they wanted to keep fighting
Halifax recorded in his diary well
Winston talked the most frightful rot it
drives him to despair
Churchill's driven by emotion that
previous oration to the cabinet its
emotion driving Churchill when he ought
to have his brain thinking reasoning the
reasonable person would try to cut a
deal at this time
indeed revisionist historians when
writing about Churchill say that
Churchill might have made the right
decision in 1940 to fight on but it
wasn't based on reason it was all based
on emotion I'm going to argue against
that yes there's great emotion involved
of course there is they're involved in a
war a struggle for survival
people are indeed emotional in those
situations they're fighting for
something that they care dearly about
but that doesn't mean that the brain was
turned off at that time Churchill is
also offering good and reasoned
arguments for why to fight on
well rumors of divisions in the British
government get back to Germany and
indeed dr. Goebbels is confining to his
diary the war is gonna come to an end
soon
by the end of June the German leadership
thinks as a chance for a negotiated
peace with Britain the Churchill will be
removed from government he'll be
replaced by somebody else and that new
government will be willing to negotiate
with Germany they're close to the end of
the war well Churchill's of the response
is pretty clear and again the speeches
are not just to the British people but
also to the enemy to show resolve and
one of his great speeches he highlights
that if Britain is invaded the British
people won't just lie down in submission
they'll fight they'll defend every
village every town every city indeed
London itself could
turned into a vast fortress if it's
fought out again think of the Battle of
Stalingrad and the battles of the Second
World War that in fought in cities here
Churchill is imagining this this is also
an implicit dig at the French because
the French declared Paris an open city
not to be fought over in 1940
unlike in 1871 when Paris wonder when a
siege in the franco-prussian war
so Churchill is saying we're not going
to behave like that we're going to fight
it out in the cities and then again look
at this line I'm bound to state these
faculty our people to inform them and to
reassure them and again you a
bloodthirsty speech like that you would
think that would frighten people but it
doesn't it shows that the leadership is
determined to see things through well
Hitler has a response today historians
do not pay enough attention to Hitler's
speeches they should be read it is
amazing how revealing these speeches are
of Hitler he's not keeping things secret
he's telling people what he thinks and
so in response to Churchill's speech he
comes out with his so-called peace
appeal of July 19 1940 mr. Churchill
declares he wants the war to continue a
great Empire will be destroyed I don't
want to destroy him again I want to cut
a deal to preserve the British Empire
but it's clear that this struggle will
end in the destruction of one or two if
Churchill is remaining in power
Churchill thinks that it will be Germany
I'll know it it's England again look at
this at this hour I feel compelled by
conscience
Hitler's conscience how big is that
small for anything okay
appeal to reason in England again here
it is he's appealing to reason in
England the Churchill's decisions are
emotional rather than based on prudence
on care in a careful way thinking
through odds probabilities strengths of
both sides well why make peace a good
argument could be made for why to make
peace here's the argument
that were made at the time they're
actually quite compelling they're very
strong reasons again if you're sitting
there in 1940 and you're looking at the
future
well France your main allies defeated
the British armies been disarmed Italy
and Japan are gonna come in against you
again it looks pretty bleak these are
the arguments that are being raised at
the time and again in this emotional
environment arguments are being put
forward and Churchill is answering
though indeed in one of his famous
speeches from 1940 he says we have good
and reasonable hopes for final victory
now why did he believe that well this is
his counter-argument that Britain could
build up its airpower defend the
homeland with its airpower build up a
big bomber force to take the fight to
Germany it can defend it sea lanes that
can carry out offensives in the Middle
East against Italy support insurgencies
in Europe and eventually work toward an
alliance with the United States what's
key here is that the decision for
Britain to fight on is based on a wager
that Churchill is making a bet that he
is making that the United States will
come through ultimately and see this
fight against Nazi Germany as a fight
that the United States also has to fight
again this is key this is a big takeaway
my students like to use the phrase a
take away what can you learn from
history well here's something I think is
a very powerful lesson for our partners
around the world their decisions about
how to behave in their foreign policy is
predicated upon their reading of the
United States and our willingness to
back them up I think that's a very
powerful takeaway that we should always
keep in mind well in the first world war
Churchill served as ministry munitions
in Britain dr. Larian has a wonderful
study that he's written about Churchill
as minister of munitions and in one of
his speeches in the First World War
Churchill said how I was Britain going
to win the first world war against
Imperial Germany two A's airplanes in
America there's a great deal of
continuity between Churchill's views
in the First World War in the Second
World War this is what he's arguing
later on in 1940 that the United States
is going to tip the balance so that the
complete defeat of Germany can be
accomplished by the way
Churchill just doesn't make decisions on
his own he goes to the British Chiefs of
Staff and here's the staff paper that
was laid out and it's called British
strategy and a certain eventualities
this is from the end of May that certain
eventualities that France is going to
fold and won't continue to fight and
will surrender to Germany and what the
British Chiefs argue in this because
Churchill says what are our chances of
holding on and the Chiefs come back and
say hey we can continue to fight if the
United States gives us that economic and
financial support but the caveat if they
don't have that support from the United
States then we do not think we could
continue the war with any chance of
success again the United States role is
key in 1940 will the u.s. come through
and the other big unknown big question
mark is will the British people be able
to withstand an aerial assault a bombing
campaign against them this is a big
question mark leaders in the Great
Powers didn't know whether their
populous their peoples how they would
react to being attacked from the air
well Churchill's great speech finest
hour that the Battle of Britain is about
to begin and what's at stake nothing
less than the survival of Christian
civilization an existential fight at the
heart of Western civilization the stakes
are high and Hitler knows that he's got
to throw everything at Britain if he has
any chance to continue the war
Sir Robert hardy talked about this the
sunlit uplands again the language of
Churchill that proved so inspiring
notice again in this famous finest hour
speech he highlights that the whole
world is in danger including the United
States the United States might feel
secure in the Western Hemisphere but it
won't be secure in a world dominated by
these authoritarian disciplined states
and again this new Dark Age because
science and technology you know one of
the questions raised at lunchtime for
Richard about 50 years hence
what role does technology play well
technology in the hands of evil men can
lead to great wickedness brace
themselves for this fight and it'll be
known as their finest hour well here's
the British response it's no longer
peace its we will never surrender I love
this David Lowe cartoon look at this
cartoon look what it shows it shows
British political leaders Churchill at
the front of this phalanx behind him
Neville Chamberlain Clement Attlee
Beaverbrook Halifax Leo Amery eat and
the British politicians all lined up and
notice what's happened they've taken off
their jackets they've rolled up their
sleeves this is a bare-knuckles fight no
Marquita Queensberry rules here this is
a real bloody fight that's going to
happen and look all behind you Winston
the country's united in this
bare-knuckle fight well
the Straits of Dover are not very wide
are they he was going in his enter osh
the Air Force German air force looking
across at the White Cliffs of Dover
great danger can Britain stand up to
this aerosol indeed the German Air Force
is ready to give it a try dr. Goebbels
in fact Commission's a song bombs on
England you can go to youtube and hear
it if you want to but here are some of
the lyrics the German pilots are pumped
their morale is high they want to
destroy the British Empire again that
generation that grew up what did they
remember from the first world war the
hunger blockade of Britain they were
hungry as young people why because of
the British blockade
it's great hatred of Britain in Germany
and gurbles is playing this up so you
have highly motivated German airforce
trying to take the fight to be in the
vanguard to destroy the British Empire
and again the refrain is bombs bombs
bombs on England well will Britain be
able to stand up to it our ambassador
Joseph Kennedy wrote to his son JFK in
August the whole crux of the matter is
this air battle if the Germans can come
over and knock off the British Royal Air
Force well then the Germans will be able
to carry out an invasion of Britain and
that no country can stand up to another
country if it loses air superiority
it's the crux of the fight look at that
young JFK there by the way it's
important to remember that the Battle of
Britain of 1940 was not the first Battle
of Britain in the first world war
Britain was bombed by German Zeppelin's
and heavy bombers and indeed during the
First World War the British erected air
defenses against the German bomber
campaign throughout the whole interwar
period they also looked to the danger of
a renewed air assault in the British
homeland so the British were preparing
for this over a generation they
understood that what happened in the
First World War could happen again
so Britain is prepared to a remarkable
degree more than any other country to be
able to defend their homeland from air
attack and in charge of the British
defenses as Air Marshal Sir you downing
the the really the best commander to be
in charge of this particular fight very
cautious commander one that is quite
good at defending standing on the
defence and we know about the dogfights
in the battle taking place over Britain
Churchill's famous words about how the
whole world war how the fate of Western
civilization hinges on the actions of a
few thousand pilots fighting it out over
over the British homeland now how close
the run thing was the Battle of Britain
I mean that's a question that historians
argue today the consensus is that it
actually wasn't such a close thing
and what you see here are as the table
of single-engine fighter aircraft and
during this attrition battle in the air
over Britain the British Royal Air Force
in single-engine fighter pilot strength
gets stronger over the battle meanwhile
the Luftwaffe the German air force gets
weaker during this battle Britain's
winning it and getting stronger as the
fight goes on the odds of Germany
invading Britain then are actually quite
low and then of course once you get into
the winter weather the full weather an
invasion becomes impossible because of
the weather now that doesn't mean
however that the bomber can't get
through
and indeed the German bombers did get
through here's a frightening picture a
German HG 111 - engine bomber flying
over the Thames River over the heart of
London in daylight dropping bombs on the
east end and this iconic photograph of
course of st. Paul's Cathedral in the
East End being engulfed city of being
engulfed by fire this is Bristol in the
spring of 1941 a poor area being bombed
again who do you see there of course
Churchill his wife Clementine commenting
is there with with him again Churchill
this is a photograph taken on September
11th 1940 Buckingham Palace being bombed
when I see these photographs I think
about our September 11th in 2001 the
amount of damage that Germany is doing
to Britain from the late summer to the
end of the calendar year 1940 in other
words late summer through the fall early
winter of 1940 is the 25,000 British
civilians non-combatants are killed by
German bombing put that on the scale of
September 11th 2001
in other words Britain is taking a
punishment the equivalent over several
months of 7 or 8 September 11th attacks
again a great deal of damage is being
done
Britain but yet Britain's will is not
broken by that type of assault on their
homeland the House of Commons being
destroyed in the spring of 41 again when
I look at this photograph I think about
our September 11th experience that forth
the airliner where was that going was it
going to the White House to Capitol Hill
we don't know but we do know one thing
the bravery of the people who were on
that airliner when they got on that
airliner that day they didn't think they
were fighting for their life or fighting
to preserve some National Monument and
to save the lives of thousands of others
and yet that's what they did
just think how heroic those people are
that took matters into their own hands
and fought on September 11th rather than
let that fourth airliner go into the
Capitol or go into the White House again
when I look at how the destruction of
the House of Commons it's not hard to
imagine even more damage to Washington
on September 11th but for the bravery of
those passengers on that airliner well
the bet the Churchill placed in the
United States as it turned out it was a
good one because he found in Roosevelt a
partner who also saw the danger from
Nazi Germany who saw this as an
ideological fight as well and so
Churchill and Roosevelt this is going to
be one of the great partnerships that's
going to the lead to the defeat of Nazi
Germany now Germany has attacked Britain
it's tried to break Britain it can't
defeat Britain so what is Hitler do well
the next year attacks the Soviet Union
today we know the history of what
happens and we say why would he do such
a stupid thing what a foolish thing to
do he did it because of the two
scenarios continue the campaign
full-bore against Britain or attack the
Soviet Union he thought attacking the
Soviet Union was the simpler task now we
know otherwise but again it shows
something about British resistance in
1940 how important that was in shaping
Hitler's decisions he didn't think he
could
in against Britain he thought he could
only win by first taking the Soviet
Union out and hence he turned against
the Soviet Union
Britain's stand in other words in 1940
lays the foundation for the grand
alliance that is going to form of the
United States the Soviet Union and
Britain Britain stand becomes a rallying
point for other countries to stand up
against Nazi Germany and here you see
off the coast of Newfoundland in August
1941 Churchill and Roosevelt getting
together to do the Atlantic Charter
I like this photograph because the two
admirals there are Admiral Ernest King
and Admiral Harold Stark
they are both graduates of the Naval War
College in Newport Rhode Island where I
teach so I'm putting in a plug there for
my school it just shows that we
contribute to the victory as well in the
Second World War education leading to a
better educated officer corps capable of
making good strategic decisions well
there there's my plug for my school and
for my job ok liberators of the world
this is how we remember this partnership
again one of the big takeaways is
Churchill's bet is that the British
people would prove resilient and be
willing to fight on
Churchill's bet was also that the United
States would come through last night
Sir Robert Hardy gave that wonderful
rendition of this famous speech on
Churchill's 80th birthday and again in
modesty Churchill highlights that it was
the British people who were resolute
remorseless and unconquerable and again
he learned his trade of being a great
orator and writer that he was able to
give Lionheart there of the British
people and he had the luck to give the
roar well we know that Churchill's
contribution was more than just the roar
that his leadership at a critical time
was of the utmost importance for making
sure that Nazi Germany was indeed
defeated
that history didn't turn in that awful
way that our worst imaginations that
those things that we could imagine of
how dreadful things could be did not
happen thank you very much
thank you so much dr. malware we will
now have time for one or two questions
if you have a question please raise your
hand the microphone won't be brought to
you yet
in 1938 Neville Chamberlain made this
agreement in Munich with Herr Hitler and
Churchill observed them that England was
offered a choice between shame and war
they choose shame and would get war yes
just this year
John Kerry went to Vienna to make an
agreement with ayatollah khomeini we
were offered a choice between shame or
war which we choose shame is that do you
see a church on the horizon that can
rescue the Western civilization again in
response to your question first let me
say that and I have to say this so I
apologize to you but I am a government
employee and that what I'm going to say
does not reflect the opinion of the
Department of Defense the US Navy or the
Naval War College it is only my own
personal opinion but but I need to say
that first of course you would all
understand that anyway but it is a
regulation that I am asked to follow it
is a big question when you're cutting
deals with regimes that are revisionist
regimes that want to change around the
balance of power as Iran does in the
Middle East cutting deals with them is
that in your interest does that make a
ran stronger anything that moves Iran
toward getting nuclear weapons is a
danger the argument often goes something
like this and if Iran gets nuclear
weapons they'll feel more secure and
hence they will be less dangerous I yeah
I I don't abide by that I buyed there's
something simpler and I think more
realistic which is the more powerful
some country does be
the more they become ambitious and so I
think an Iran armed with nuclear weapons
will be more dangerous not less
dangerous so anything that can be done
to impede that should be done and indeed
you when you look at the Middle East the
potential danger there is immense
because already you know if Iran gets
nuclear weapons then what Sunni States
might want to get nuclear weapons may be
working with Pakistan you could have a
nuclear-armed middle-east a nuclear arms
race in the Middle East how long before
that explodes into a nuclear arm again
on there so very dangerous environment
I've talked with several of you over
lunch my own view is III don't think we
should have signed such a deal I think
we should have continued on to the next
presidency I think it would be good for
the US Congress to take a stand against
it because it will at the very least
strengthen the hand of either this
president or the next president in what
they want to do with Iran so having said
that there's arguments on both sides for
the agreement but I think on balance I I
don't like the agreement but
good afternoon sir I had a question
regarding the graph you showed us on the
force of Luftwaffe aeroplanes and how
that was decreasing was that just
because of the superiority of the
British aircraft or what were the
Germans focusing their manufacturing and
other areas over that period of months I
was just curious on why the numbers were
going down so drastically for the German
it's training of pilots and production
of airframes and what happened was that
Germany Germany stole a march on Britain
by about one year an air rearmament if
Britain had rearm sooner you might not
have had the catastrophe of France in
1940 so I think Churchill's warnings
were were well taken and if he had been
heeded Britain and France would have
been better prepared to fight what this
shows is that Britain is able to train
pilots and produce enough airframes to
be able to keep ahead of the Germans who
at this time are not keeping the same
number of trained pilots in fact one of
the things that's striking when Hitler
attacks the Soviet Union the German air
force over the Soviet Union is weaker
weaker than the German air force that
attacked France in 1940 so again the
losses suffered by the Luftwaffe in the
Battle of France and in the Battle of
Britain and then the air forces that
have to be left behind to defend Western
Europe against British air assault means
that Germany is less powerful when
attacks the Soviet Union and that could
have made a measure of difference of
whether the Germans take Moscow and
Leningrad or not so what you have here
is a combination of training and
production of air flame frames and
forces getting out to the front these
are the best latest numbers by air
historians on this and it tends to show
that the Battle of Britain as I said it
was not as close run a thing as we often
think now having said that the margin
for error here
is none too great and if you had had a
less competent commander than then
doubting you you could have thrown away
whatever advantages you're deriving at
this time and of course the British are
pulling out all the stops to maximize
air production and training of pilots at
this time does that get to your question
Jen the mind is related to the previous
gentleman this is a measurement of pilot
or is this a measurement of aircraft of
aircraft and and deployable fighting
strength okay
now I'm wondering how much of that was
actually imported from the United States
through some sort of a lend-lease
program at that time not not at this
time this is British production that's
going on and again I want to highlight
that this is just single-engine fighter
strike that doesn't include bombers and
you know in other measures so I have
singled out you know one element of
airpower here in this if you were to
take a larger picture you would find
that the Germans also have a large
bomber force but this is the key
indicator of what's going to determine
the outcome of the Battle of Britain at
this time American aid is not that great
you get the 50 destroyer deal that comes
along lend-lease isn't until March 1941
the thinking in Britain is that like the
Great War that Roosevelt has an election
looming in 1940 and this is a
fascinating story by the way because as
you know Roosevelt ran for a third term
an unprecedented third term breaking the
tradition of George Washington of two
terms and in the spring of 1940 before
the fall of France Roosevelt was not
didn't think he had any chance of
winning the presidency indeed opinion
polls were showing that if he were to
run he would not win a third term but
the defeat of France changes around
American views and hence Roosevelt gets
a spike up where he's willing to go if
drafted and so his party does so the
full of France has a big impact on
American domestic politics in enabling
the American people to get accustomed to
the
idea of Roosevelt is the only person
that could lead us through this crisis
and hence he runs as successfully for a
third term now the British view is until
the first Tuesday of November 1940
you're not going to get a firm American
policy because Roosevelt before an
election can't go too far ahead of
American opinion the hope is that maybe
in the spring things will change around
as it turns out as you know we don't
enter the war until December 7th 1941
when a gia Japan attacks us and then
several days later we get involved in
the European war when Hitler declares
war on us which is a fascinating speech
to listen to by the way to read in which
Hitler lays out in a incredibly
revealing way his ideologies world view
of how there's this vast conspiracy
against him in the German people it's a
very peculiar speech does that answer
your question
thank you thank you again dr. Maurer our
reception will begin in the Searle
Center and dinner thereafter see you
back at 8 o'clock